'operación unicornio' así se llama el
dispositivo secreto que acaba de
activarse la reina isabel segunda ha
dado su último aliento en balmoral en
escocia se trata en primer lugar de la
suspensión del parlamento escocés a la
espera de un funeral de estado el cuerpo
será entonces llevado a la catedral de
sangin en edimburgo para los primeros
homenajes a la monarca en el tren real
el féretro saldrá entonces de escocia
hacia inglaterra las etapas del
protocolo del london bridge han sido
cuidadosamente preparadas desde los años
60 todas las banderas del país ondean a
media asta al son de las campanas del
'big ben' las dos cámaras del parlamento
se reúnen a continuación antes de un
discurso del príncipe carlos por
televisión
pero no es hasta el día siguiente a las
11 en punto que el hijo sucederá a la
madre para convertirse en el rey de
inglaterra en una reunión del consejo
celebrada en el palacio de saint james a
esto le seguirán conmemoraciones para la
difunta reina en todo el reino unido
donde el futuro rey se reunirá con
líderes de la commonwealth o en escocia
irlanda del norte y gales la reina ha
muerto viva el rey pero el reino
comienza un período de luto nacional de
10 días en cuanto muere isabel segunda
en los días siguientes según el
protocolo el féretro es transportado
desde el palacio de buckingham al
palacio de westminster en una procesión
militar por las calles de la capital
londres
a continuación los restos de las reinas
son velados durante tres días 23 horas
al día isabel segunda ya será en su
ataúd con el orbe el cetro en la corona
imperial que le fueron confiados en 1953
en su coronación tiempo para que un
pueblo afligido se despida antes del
funeral que tendrá lugar en la abadía de
westminster nueve días después de su
muerte el reino guardará dos minutos de
silencio y al final de la ceremonia el
cuerpo será transportado en el mismo
coche utilizado para el funeral de su
padre jorge sexto en 1952 un viaje hacia
su última morada en el castillo de
windsor donde la reina descansará para
la eternidad junto al príncipe felipe el
protocolo london bridge llegará entonces
a su fin dando paso a sprint aid la
operación paralela que prevé la llegada
al trono de su hijo carlos